human brain is an incredible super
computer
[Music]
and they're like a
it
it has
100 trillion parameters
or like a if you try to count various
quantities in the brain there are like a
neurons synapses that small number of
neurons there is a lot of synapses yeah
it's unclear even how to map
synapses
to uh to parameters of neural networks
but it's clear that there are many more
yeah um so it might be the case that our
networks are still somewhat small
it also might be the case that they are
more efficient than brain or less
efficient by some by some huge factor
i also believe that there will be okay
you know at the moment we are at the
stage that the these neural networks
they require 1000x or like a huge factor
of more data than humans do and it will
be a matter of uh
um
there will be algorithms that
vastly decrease sample complexity i
believe so but the place where we are
heading today is dark domains which
contains millions
more data and even though computers
might be 1 000 times slower than humans
in learning that's not the problem okay
for instance
i believe that
it should be possible to create super
human therapies
uh by uh
and and then they're like even simple
steps of of doing what of of doing it
and you know that the core reason is
there is just
machine will be able to read way more
transcripts of therapies and then it
should be able to speak simultaneously
with many more people and it should be
possible to optimize it uh all in
parallel
and well there's now you're touching on
something i deeply care about and think
is way harder than we imagined
um
what's the goal of a therapist what's
that called therapies
so okay so one goal now this is
terrifying to me
but there's a lot of people that
contemplate suicide suffer from
depression
and they could significantly be helped
with therapy
and the idea that an ai algorithm might
be in charge of that
it's like a life and death task
it's uh
the stakes are high
so one
goal for a therapist whether human or ai
is to prevent suicide ideation to
prevent suicide how do you achieve that
so
let's see
to be clear i don't think that the
current models are good enough for such
a task because it requires insane amount
of understanding and patty and the
models are far from this place but it's
but do you think that understanding
empathy that signal is in the data
i think there is some signal in the data
yes i mean there are plenty of
transcripts of conversations and it is
possible to
it is possible from it to understand
personalities it is possible from it to
understand uh if conversation is
friendly
uh amicable uh
antagonistic it is i believe that the
you know given the fact that the models
that we train now
they can
uh
they can have
they are chameleons that they can have
any personality they might turn out to
be better in understanding
uh personality of other people than
anyone else and they feel pathetic to be
empathetic yeah
interesting uh but
i wonder if there's some level
of
multiple modalities required
to be able to um be empathetic of the
human experience
whether language is not enough to
understand death to understand fear to
understand
uh childhood trauma
to understand uh wit and humor required
when you're dancing with the person who
might be depressed or suffering
both humor and hope and love and all
those kinds of things
so there's another underlying question
which is self-supervised versus
supervised
so can you get that
from the data by just reading
a huge number of transcripts i actually
so i think that reading huge number of
transcripts is a step one it's like the
same way as you cannot learn to dance if
just from youtube by watching it you
have to actually try it out yourself
yeah and so i think that here that's the
similar situation i also wouldn't deploy
the system in the high-stakes situations
right away but kind of see gradually
where
it goes and obviously initially uh it
would have to go hand with a hand in
hand with humans but
at the moment we are in the situation
that actually
there is many more people who actually
would like to have a therapy or or speak
with with someone then there are
therapists out there okay you know i was
so so
fundamentally i was thinking what are
the things that
can vastly increase people well-being
therapy is one of them i think
meditation is other one i guess maybe
human connection is a third one and i
guess
pharmacologically it's also possible
maybe direct brain stimulation or
something like that but these are pretty
much options out there then let's say
the way i'm thinking about the agi
endeavor is by default that's an
endeavor to
increase amount of wealth and i believe
that we can vastly increase amount of
wealth
for everyone and simultaneously so i
mean these are like two endeavors that
make sense to me one is like essentially
increase the amount of wealth and second
one is uh increase overall human
well-being
and those are coupled together and that
they they can okay i would say these are
different topics one can help another
you